d'habitude il incarne le calme
l'écoutent
mais aujourd'hui ils ont laissé éclater
leur colère en allusion 26 patients de
les passions en isolement
feytiat maltraitance institutionnelle
c'est la mort de la psychiatrie khiari
les infirmiers psychiatriques sont
inquiets d'ici à 2021 ils vont perdre
une centaine de postes dans le jura
l'hôpital de saintes il lit le plus
vieil hôpital psychiatrique de la région
est en première ligne au niveau des
admissions on était quatre matins on va
être plus que deux je pense que la
violence
énergie de plus en plus des gens en
crise si on peut pas prendre du temps
avec eux on pourra pas apaiser la crise
ces gens là vont ils ont fini renfermé
nous on veut pas de ça on veut pas d'une
psychiatrie carcéral
saintes il y a déjà perdu 26 postes
cette année
les personnels ont donc planté 26 croix
dans l'entrée de l'hôpital avec un
message entre humour triste et désespoir
de son côté la direction ne confirme pas
les suppressions de postes mais précise
que les temps changent et sainte il ya
peut-être moins besoin de personnel
aujourd'hui on rentre plus à saint-élie
pour des années comme ça pouvait être le
cas il ya encore quelques décennies
quand on rentre à saint-élie c'est pour
un programme de soins et ce programme de
soins doit après se poursuivre à
l'extérieur on suit davantage de
personnes mais en hospitalise mois
l'hôpital compte un peu plus de 1000
salariés
les suppressions de postes pourraient
entraîner la fermeture de plusieurs
services
un effet de bascule aggravée par la
pénurie de médecins psychiatres plus
d'un poste sur trois est vacant
aujourd'hui dans les établissements
publics de franche comté